E aí
[Aplausos]
o futebol traz felicidade do ser humano
de viver em coletividade Olha a
histórias que diz O homem é um ser
social na medida em que eles precisa de
estabelecer relações sociais para
sobreviver e para realizar mais essa
convivência social está com vivência em
comunidade nos diria proveitosa Se cada
um executar as estou Boa tarde as suas
paixões e seus vícios as suas
publicações sem considerar o interesse
Todos nós sabemos que o ser humano
quando a tua que forma desligada
normalmente se transforma no seu próprio
Lobo aliás existe uma frase Latina
Eu como carne duplos significa o homem é
o seu próprio Lobo que se fossemos
pensar em alguma coisa que nos traz isso
basta nós sabemos para as causas e as
consequências das alterações climáticas
do mundo inteiro para percebermos que o
homem pode ser o seu próprio Lobo
bom então
e havia
o que criar regras de convivência para
acomodar os interesses individuais e
preços contradições e até interesses
conflituantes dos membros da sociedade e
criar direitos e deveres para cada um
criar os direitos e deveres ou melhor
obrigações da própria sociedade e também
como regular as relações entre o homem e
a sociedade Onde está inserido e todas
essas regras de convivência social é
aquilo que nós chamamos de direito mas
parece direito
a ser imposto a própria sociedade sobre
que une esforços individuais para criar
um entre coletivo uma cidade maior
Supremo e abstrata que nós chamamos
estado o estado representa a
coletividade e no campo do Direito com
petroestado aprovar o direito garantir o
seu comprimento e finalizar o respectivo
incumprimento nós podemos pensar pão
creme de leite temos estado estados a
prova direito está dizer quanto ao
direito que aprovou Então esse Estado
está cumprir com seu papel social vão É
verdade nós temos vários exemplos mais
ou menos recente na história da
humanidade tem que determinar diz forças
do mal dominaram a superestrutura de
status e usaram direito até para
perseguir os criminosos em Speed
o Finn nomes curiosos como por exemplo a
finalização da escravatura o
colonialismo o nazismo e deixa uma parte
aqui na vizinha África do Sul mostram
que esses fenômenos foram justificados a
luz de um Celta dentes mas fizemos vai
recentemente podemos ver situações sabe
que estabelece nas suas constituições um
conjunto de direitos liberdades e
garantias dos cidadãos muito altos e de
última geração mas que não fundo a maior
parte de cidadãos não se beneficia desse
jeito temos estádios
e também são muito ricos recursos
naturais mas só uma minoria tem que
tirar proveito desses dessa riqueza
então aí nesses países nós temos estádio
nós temos uma constituição e tem normas
que visam garantir o bem-estar do
cidadão Teoricamente temos tribunais Que
alegadamente visão unir injustiças mas o
que nós encontramos é se devemos da
Ribeira na maior injustiça cidadãos a
viver em e níveis a paz está mais lindos
da atividade ser humano
bom então o que que foi que que acontece
aí na maior parte das vezes é que a
finalidade do direito foi submetida por
uma minoria poderosa e se eu protejo e
em violação de direitos e interesses da
maioria e
bom então precisamos de ter cuidad
e não é tudo em qualquer direito que
serve para mudar a sociedade para lidar
como vimos existe jeito que pode ser
usado abusivamente para corromper a
sociedade é preciso distinguir o bom
direito do mouse e o dinheiro que pode
ser usado para ajudar a melhorar a
sociedade é o bom direito maskesi
direito tem que ser aplicado
é para ser aceite como vão direito que
eu tenho que ser aplicado numa forma que
ele provém da vontade da maioria dos
cidadãos é aplicado no interesse dessa
Maria G executado por instituições que
visam a garantir esse fim que estamos é
indicado então aí nós seríamos por lá e
com direito por outro lado tivemos um
estar capaz pode para implementar
corretamente essa conjugação de bom
direito e estado surgem dentro está
direito está direito não é nada mais
nada menos que o estado democrático que
na sua atuação segue primeiramente por
regras do direito
e mais a minha posição em que nós não
conseguimos produzir o direito nem
conseguimos constituir um estado de
direito se não estivermos numa sociedade
com Maria de cidadãos e letra A
Oi e Para apoiar essa ideia eu peço aqui
coloque resto flagra eu fui pois dentro
das Nações Unidas com inscrito em
movimento Marlene seus vídeos tô aqui
2019 e vocês vem aí o capital do
desenvolvimento humano o campeão é
Noruega depois tem a Suíça e Holanda no
top ou menos países como Alemanha Suécia
Austrália Holanda Dinamarca e Cingapura
no lado contrário fui espreitar os 12
últimos países do mesmo ente e protejo
Mano vocês vem com o último lugar além
canta vermelho ninja com as tempo
República centro-africano diz que
estudamos elaborou the Male serralhao
infelizmente não sabe entregue eu posso
fazer trata do Congo ver
e o que é que não existe que o capital
humano é um fator decisivo para o
desenvolvimento da sociedade
É que ontem a conhecimento educação a
maior chance de desenvolvimento que é
uma relação intensa entre a educação e o
desenvolvimento e no lado contrário
entra em vigor ânsia e o seu
desenvolvimento
e olha essa madeira que disso a
diferença entre privilegiada e
desprivilegiada Poderosos de
marginalidade o mesa essencialmente no
acesso à educação e o conhecimento essa
frase também pode ser completada por uma
frase de Benjamin para mim e diz se
achas que educação aí cara então
experimentam a ignorância essas ideias
nos dizem que
E nós queremos sempre a sociedade pagar
sempre um preço muito elevado
a pena existência de analfabetismo pela
carência de educação e essa presa muitas
vezes em traduzido em realidade com uma
foto presa miséria violência mortes
prematuras onde justificados por isso
nós podemos concordar todos que o
diâmetro pode ser uma ferramenta para
mudar para melhor na sociedade Mas para
que ele seja essa ferramenta a uma
condição e ultrapassado a maioria do
cidadão tem que ter cultura jurídica
e eu não sabia e fiz inscrito na
Constituição como direito fundamental o
direito à manifestação as regras têm que
o estado tudo faz para que um cidadão
francês muitas vezes recorrendo a
integração EA violência
há 14 anos que existe um problema sério
de ratos empresários e seus familiares
em Moçambique que são devolvidos ao
convívio social em troca de botox
Resgate que Nascente São Paulo estão na
ideia sua em dois meses de 20 no ano
passado cerca de 16 de empresários ou
familiar foram raptados por criminosos
que nos amigo
o estado não tem conseguido combater
esta realidade as vítimas EA sociedade
civil tenta ser tão generalizada que o
estado não consegue combater por me a
infiltração 2013 tendências criminosas
dentro do estado e
o importado de vou explicar Quais são as
consequências drásticas socioeconómicas
de crescimento de uma indústria de
gelados de empresário no país durante
ser porque isso vem acontecendo há cerca
de 11 anos o governo optou por uma
estratégia de silêncio sobre essa
realidade
e deixar para a polícia falar isso é um
caso de polícia 1 2 3 4 5 10 20 a
polícia vinha falaram com a imprensa
dizia que estava a trabalhar a expressão
É essa mesmo estamos a trabalhar mas
desde então o resultados têm sido
satisfatórios pelo contrário ao invés de
combater os ratos pode controlar a
criminalidade ela aumentou
exponencialmente
bom então e a imprensa as associações de
verdade também tinha uma intervenção
muito tímida em consistência no debate
deste problema que estava a cor que está
correndo a sociedade dos alimentos Então
em Outubro de dois mil e vinte Tudo
Mudou
e o grupo de aniversário aqui da cidade
de Aveiro cria um movimento cidadania
iluminado Beira WhatsApp
o grupo convocou uma conferência de
imprensa e para todo o país deu uma
mensagem de repúdio contra incapacidade
de status de controlar rica
o estado Comprido com as suas principais
funções sociais e funções jurídicas que
lhe garantir a segurança dos televisão
no caso dos seus interessados nessa
mesma conferência de imprensa eles
anunciam impor texto que ele não
estragar os seus negócios seus
estabelecimentos comerciais por três
dias e
e eu considero que esta manifestação Foi
um sucesso e foi o sucesso porque porque
a partir daí que ela é moça abrir a
sociedade começou a discutir entre grave
problema de lápis suas causas
consequências razões Porque não são
combatidos e como deve ser com o médico
a imprensa urbanas de assunto de um
destaque e nove pela primeira vez o
Presidente da República veio a público
falar sobre essa realidade admitido Em
capacidade de estados americanos e
combater eficazmente a este crime desse
discurso no Parlamento o Presidente da
República veio dizer que o estado
moçambicano iria solicitar apoio
internacional para ajudar a combater Zap
e e criar uma unidade especial da
polícia uma polícia a tilápia
tá bom
a área procuração pública dessa
manifestação vou então pode tão marcante
que o de jornais mais prestigiados de
Moçambique escolheu o movimento de
nativos como uma das figuras de destaque
do ano Deus me livre nós podemos ver na
tela a matéria de jornal trabalho pode
lá no fundo temos arrepiante imagem e o
movimento Beira di Latte usa nas suas
aparições públicas e temos um sugestivo
título dado pela redação de jornal
empresários Indomáveis controlado e
depois temos aí uma série de
justificação de porque o jornal Savana a
equipe o movimento perante lá tu foi uma
das figuras de destaque do ano 2020
bom então a partir de uma manifestação
pacífica e ordeira de empresários locais
foi possível retirar sobre mundo
prometido silêncio um assunto de tamanha
importância para a sociedade moçambicana
que estavam Rua estruturas
econômico-sociais cidade tem colocar o
conjunto dos principais assuntos de
discussão
em público
é a visão O que é que morreu enterra o
que é que tinham o que tinha de especial
quer dizer passares
e para criar super à vontade mesmo
assunto um assunto tão importante e
colocar os amigos dele igual a
o pão para além de dente coragem quem
não tem um metro e o silêncio eles nada
mais nada menos quiseram recusar com
esse o direito à manifestação está
escrito na constituição para te mandar
melhorias na sociedade moçambicana e o
rei quer mais uma vez é possível usar o
direito como instrumento para melhorar a
sociedade mas para isso é primeiro lugar
é necessário cultivar e ampliar a
cultura jurídica do cidadão não parece
que a gente esse nos nossos jovens
Matemática Português biologia etc e não
existe temos também
a formação jurídica elementar
o cão entendimento não são as básicas de
direito deveriam fazer parte do
currículo do ensino secundário para que
nós no futuro possamos ter cidadãos
juridicamente cultos e esse gente ainda
que sejam profissionais da área de
medicina da área das engenharias da área
do ensino ou de qualquer outra profissão
dá um jeito eu entendo também que o
estado Às vezes as organizações
não-governamentais as empresas devem
investir na educação científica para
melhorar e ampliar a cultura jurídica
ocidental e
oi oi buscar já vídeos 500 não se pede
direitos existentes e com os dois meses
nestas cidades mais desenvolvidas
é o primeiro defensor do estado de
direito democrático e cidadão e a
primeira função coletiva quem a
cidadania II
e eu quero te perguntar se tu
se vocês querem Viver num país melhor
eu quero deixar um país melhor pois você
Felipe
e quem vive dentro estado em que o
direito seja efetivamente uma ferramenta
para desenvolver a sociedade
e as portas 3 pistões o assim então
vamos todos nos unir e como referência
aplicativo sabe que cada seja
Brasiliense e resiliência é um tema do
nosso técnico com experiência Vamos
todos trabalhar para conseguir obter uma
cidadania mais curta e juridicamente g a
Band o país a vende todos nós